[Aplausos]
[Música]
para nuestro deber del one y míguens el
violín en el suelo
woods en juegos de estos vinos en una
tienda del trabajo interno el fútbol
un combate entre millonarios para ver
quién se hace con los mandos del país
más poderoso del mundo ese es el
escenario soñado por michael bloomberg
un hombre de negocios reconvertido en
todo un político camaleónico ni a la
izquierda ni a la derecha justo en medio
bloomberg es capaz de entenderse con
prácticamente todo el espectro político
de los eeuu demócrata primero más tarde
republicano independiente después y
ahora de nuevo del lado de los
demócratas como candidato a las
primarias que tienen como misión elegir
a la persona que se frente a donald
trump en las presidenciales de 2020
puede ser
que vio
[Aplausos]
pero amigos esta no es su única
característica este personaje es algo
así como el bill gates de las campañas
electorales si tal vez no sea el tipo
más carismático del mundo ni el mejor
comunicador pero siempre se sale con la
suya hasta ahora nunca ha perdido unas
elecciones y sobre todo es rico muy rico
tremendamente rico
quiénes exactamente michael bloomberg
cuál ha sido su paso por la política se
le puede comparar con donald trump
pues bien atentos al workshop
en su nombre y mail
[Música]
un pulso de carteras
multimillonario nieto de inmigrantes
propietario de una gran empresa que
lleva por nombre su apellido y uno de
los personajes más conocidos del
panorama político y económico de los
eeuu que a lo largo de los años se
identificado como el demócrata y como
republicano no no me estoy refiriendo a
donald trump sino a michael bloomberg
es igual a primera vista podrían
parecernos dos personajes muy similares
sin embargo hasta aquí llegan las
similitudes mike bloomberg es mucho más
rico que donald trump según forbes su
fortuna es ni más ni menos que 18 veces
mayor que la del actual inquilino de la
casa blanca con un patrimonio de más de
55 mil millones de dólares hablamos de
una de las 12 personas más ricas de todo
el mundo
vamos que en términos de pasta a
comparar a trump con bloomberg es como
comparar a un dacia sandero con un
bentley continental gt es cómodo y los
controles están realmente el alcance de
la mano
y no sólo eso mientras que donald trump
es básicamente un niño rico que ha
heredado una inmensa fortuna de su papá
michael bloomberg es hijo de una familia
de clase media es un hombre hecho a sí
mismo lacie la reproducción del sueño
americano
donald traen conocemos a muchas de las
mismas personas en nueva york se ríen de
ti a tus espaldas y te llaman payaso
chiflado de carnaval ellos saben que tú
heredaste una fortuna y la desperdicias
de negocios estúpidos e incompetencia
tengo el registro y los recursos para
derrotar te y lo haré michael bloomberg
en twitter
tras estudiar ingeniería eléctrica a la
universidad johns hopkins y un mba en
harvard bloomberg dio el salto a wall
street donde comenzó a trabajar en
salomón brothers uno de los grandes
bancos de inversión tras ser despedido
en 1981 fundó la bloomberg limited
partnership hoy la mayor compañía de
información y datos del planeta y es que
da trabajo a más de 20.000 personas sus
terminales son algo así como la ventana
al mundo de la industria financiera a
través de ellas puedes seguir la
cotización de prácticamente cualquier
producto financiero conocer los números
de miles y miles decenas de miles de
empresas o incluso rastrear petroleros o
averiguar dónde hay incendios forestales
eso sí si estáis pensando en haceros con
una vais a tener que preparar la cartera
porque cada licencia cuesta más de 20
mil dólares por año
pero amigos las diferencias como donald
trump no se limitan a ver quién tiene la
cartera más grande lo cierto es que
hablamos de dos tipos muy diferentes
mientras que donald trump es el rey del
espectáculo bloomberg es el rey de los
datos como antes decíamos estamos ante
el bill gates de la política
norteamericana
un tipo que sueña con dirigir los mandos
del país más poderoso del mundo a pesar
de que ya tiene ni más ni menos que 78
tacos aunque bueno no es el único
sanders bailén pelosi en el partido
demócrata parece que las caras nuevas la
sangre joven no gusta nada gusta menos
que una hamburguesa de coliflor pero
ahora bien porque dar semejante salto
que hay detrás de este candidato y sobre
todo aquí en modelo de país tiene en su
mente amigos amigas para contestar a
estas preguntas y conocer más a fondo a
este personaje creo que lo mejor es
echar un vistazo a su trayectoria
política porque si no es la primera vez
que mike bloomberg se lanza al ruedo de
la política atentos las misiones 3
nanette burstein speaking workers le
pedimos a todos los pequeños que se
mantengan en formación informados sobre
el red con sandy
el alcalde
[Música]
con el comienzo de siglo y tras haber
cumplido los 60 años bloomberg dejó los
negocios y se lanzó de lleno a la
política municipal
se presentó a la alcaldía de nueva york
y se hizo con ella sí porque a pesar de
parecer casi tan soso como el windows
vista
bloomberg nunca nunca ha perdido unas
elecciones en aquel momento la ciudad no
atravesaba precisamente por sus mejores
momentos
tras los atentados del 11 de septiembre
de nueva york seguía en shock el crimen
cotizaba más alto que las acciones de
tesla y el presupuesto municipal estaba
más en rojo que las cuentas del gobierno
argentino por aquel entonces la ciudad
atravesaba una dura crisis económica
bajo semejantes circunstancias hay que
el bloomberg fue elegido alcalde por el
partido republicano
y ojo porque el alcaldía de nueva york
puede que tal vez os parezca poca cosa
de verdad un alcalde que tiene que ver
eso con la política con letras
mayúsculas alcalde para presidente venga
ya
pues si pensáis así es simple y
llanamente porque no conocéis el
presupuesto de la ciudad de nueva york
que es gigantesco
la ciudad de nueva york no solo es la
ciudad más poblada de los eeuu sino que
tiene más habitantes que 38 de los 50
estados que forman el país durante su
mandato
bloomberg gestionó un presupuesto de
casi 70 mil millones de dólares anuales
ahora bien no penséis ni por un segundo
que fue el típico político republicano
que apuesta por bajar impuestos o
eliminar regulaciones para nada
bloomberg es una curiosa mezcla de
estereotipos norteamericanos una de sus
caras es la de un tipo duro y un
pragmático del mercado que defiende que
los negocios son lo primero la otra es
la de un político paternal que defiende
que los gobiernos trabajen en cambiar el
estilo de vida de la gente aunque eso
suponga hacerlo a golpe de regulación o
prohibiciones
ya lo veis dos en uno demócrata y
republicano y así es exactamente cómo
dirigió la ciudad de nueva york durante
sus años al frente de la alcaldía
bloomberg lideró cinco grandes políticas
por un lado ordenó las cuentas públicas
que pasaron de registrar un enorme
agujero un déficit de casi cinco mil
millones de dólares a un superávit de
más de dos mil cuatrocientos millones al
final de su mandato
eso sí para alcanzar semejante logro
bloomberg no dudó en subir impuestos
tener las cuentas ordenadas fue lo
primero
su segunda gran apuesta fue la
rezonificación de muchas partes de la
ciudad es decir impulsar nuevos
proyectos inmobiliarios y convertir
espacios degradados en nuevos barrios
cambiando los usos del suelo que es lo
que hizo por ejemplo con el proyecto del
hudson yards en el website de manhattan
una antigua zona de talleres y espacios
ferroviarios
bloomberg impulso desde el ayuntamiento
su transformación cambio los usos del
suelo aprobó un montón de incentivos
fiscales y llevó el metro que por cierto
es de competencia estatal pero como en
ese momento el estado no tenía ni dinero
ni ganas pues bloomberg hizo todo lo
posible para que fuera la ciudad quien
se encargará de financiar este proyecto
la primera ampliación del metro en más
de 25 años y el resultado es que hoy
hutson hearts es uno de los lugares de
moda un enorme complejo de 25 mil
millones con parques rascacielos de
oficinas apartamentos de lujo y centros
comerciales
[Música]
y no fue un caso aislado esta política
de renovación inmobiliaria afectó al 40
por ciento de los terrenos de la ciudad
y ha sido la responsable de la mayoría
de nuevos rascacielos parques y carriles
bici que hoy se levantan a lo largo y
ancho de toda la ciudad
su tercera política estrella fue
impulsar una transformación radical del
sistema educativo me explicó en general
los colegios públicos de nueva york-
eran tan malos que esa era la razón de
que fueran famosos
pensando en un momento cuántas películas
habéis visto de colegios e institutos de
nueva york que eran un auténtico
desastre seguro que unas cuantas
[Música]
pues bien qué pensáis que hizo el bueno
de mike pues ni más ni menos que cerrar
un montón de escuelas públicas y apostar
por las llamadas charter school es decir
escuelas gestionadas de forma
independiente pero financiadas con
dinero público
el resultado todo un éxito las tasas de
graduación en la escuela secundaria se
dispararon las charter schools estaban
mucho mejor equipadas y de repente
muchos colegios neoyorquinos se situaron
entre los mejores del país vaya cambie
[Música]
ahora bien os acordáis que habíamos
dicho que bloomberg tenía dos caras pues
bien
mike bloomberg no sólo subió los
impuestos locales también aprobó muchas
regulaciones para mejorar el estilo de
vida de los neoyorquinos a golpe de
decretazo
[Música]
bloomberg prohibió fumar en los parques
bares y restaurantes de la ciudad fue un
pionero lo hizo antes de que se
convirtiera en una moda internacional
también exigió que las cadenas de comida
rápida informarán de las calorías de
todos sus productos estableció
regulaciones muy estrictas para los
salones de bronceado e incluso quiso
prohibir la venta de refrescos gigantes
fueron medidas tan impopulares que
hicieron ganarse los apodos de la niñera
bloomberg y mejor poppins pero sabéis
que al final tuvieron un apoyo social
enorme y según el mismo defiende durante
su mandato la esperanza de vida de los
neoyorquinos creció en tres años
con todos sin género de dudas lo más
polémico de su mandato y algo que no han
dudado en utilizar sus rivales políticos
en las primarias demócratas fue sus
políticas en materia de seguridad
veréis cuando llegó a la alcaldía el
crimen seguía siendo uno de los
principales problemas de la ciudad de no
mayor por eso continuó con la conocida
como estrategia de las ventanas rotas
puesta en marcha por su predecesor el
ahora famoso abogado de trump rudy
giuliani
una estrategia que plantea que se puede
reducir el crimen creando entornos menos
hostiles y combatiendo los pequeños
actos de vandalismo o falta de cinismo
[Aplausos]
por ejemplo pensemos en un edificio con
una ventana rota si la ventana se deja
así rota si no se repara eso provocará
que se rompan las ventanas al final una
cosa llevar a la otra y a la otra el
edificio terminará destrozado y será un
nido de vandalismo y delincuencia otro
ejemplo en el que podemos pensar es en
el de la basura si en una acera se
acumula algo de basura al final toda la
calle se llenará de bolsas de basura y
suciedad quebrando así cualquier norma
básica de comportamiento social de esta
forma poco a poco se retroalimentarán
conductas incívicas que terminarán
alimentando la criminalidad
es decir en definitiva hablamos de
estrategias que persiguen reducir el
crimen generando mejores entornos y
persiguiendo los pequeños actos de
vandalismo la cuestión es que eso no fue
todo
junto a este tipo de acciones bloomberg
puso en marcha otra estrategia que a lo
largo de los años le ha costado muchos
quebraderos de cabeza la estrategia de
parar preguntar y registrar
[Música]
básicamente la idea era incrementar el
control policial en los barrios más
problemáticos y lo que termina pasando
es que casi el 90% de las personas
detenidas casadas registradas eran
personas negras o latinas por supuesto
esa cifra más del 96% eran personas
completamente inocentes a las que la
policía simplemente paraba registraba e
interrogaba por una cuestión meramente
racial
un tema que como sabéis es
particularmente tabú en los eeuu un
hispano con ropa de trabajo conduciendo
una furgoneta a por el dicho lo cual los
datos nos muestran que lo cierto es que
durante los años de este alcalde la
criminalidad se redujo un montón en
nueva york' fijaos
[Música]
está pensado fresca de méndez el
proyecto de safety frío tradicionales
piano phillips pues bien así es como
mike bloomberg transformó nueva york
pero su sueño su auténtico sueño es
hacer eso mismo pero con todo el país
atentos
un candidato diferente
amigos si algo está claro es que michael
bloomberg no es un candidato más ni
siquiera tiene que recaudar fondos para
financiar su campaña como el resto tiene
que hacer su enorme cartera le permite a
pagar todos los cheques que cuesta una
aventura como esta sin despeinarse
aunque llegará tarde a las primarias
demócratas lo hizo a lo grande tan solo
los primeros meses se ha gastado más de
400 millones de dólares en cubrir de
anuncios medio país y en contratar a un
equipo enorme de más de 2.000 personas a
los que equipados sin despeinarse con
los últimos modelos de iphone y
portátiles macbook pero la pregunta es y
todo esto para qué querían 3 defiende
este candidato qué es lo que le gustaría
hacer con los eeuu pues amigos lo que
acabamos de ver sobre lo que hizo nueva
york es un buen ejemplo de lo que
pretende ahora mike bloomberg es un tipo
pragmático con dos caras ya lo sabéis
con street is moving energy o mike dunn
[Música]
por un lado defiende subir los impuestos
a las empresas ya las personas con
mayores rentas para así cuadrar el
enorme agujero en las cuentas públicas
de más de 980 mil millones de dólares
anuales que deja trump también quiere
elevar el salario mínimo e incrementar
el control sobre las armas sin volverse
loco por otro lado quiere impulsar más
acuerdos de libre comercio reformar el
sistema migratorio para regularizar a la
mayoría de ilegales que hay en el país y
así también atraer nuevos talentos de
todo el mundo lo que podríamos llamar
canalizar los estados unidos'
por ejemplo una prueba de su estilo de
gobernar lo tenemos en su programa para
luchar contra el cambio climático a
diferencia de sus contrincantes
demócratas su plan no consiste en
grandes revoluciones sino que pasa
básicamente por cerrar las centrales de
carbón lo que es factible barato y muy
eficaz es decir para que nos entendamos
el programa político de bloomberg es
básicamente un programa aburrido no
promete nada que sea capaz de mover a
las masas ni un muro ni fuertes bajadas
de impuestos ni tampoco un greenville ni
nada por el estilo es un programa que te
puede gustar más o que te puede gustar
menos pero no levanta pasiones eso sí
son propuestas realistas esta es su
mayor debilidad y al mismo tiempo su
mayor fortaleza encontrar soluciones a
problemas difíciles es la pasión de mi
vida mis habilidades son crear y liderar
equipos que elaboren planes innovadores
y luego trabajen juntos para
implementarlos creo que esto es
exactamente lo que nuestro país necesita
de un presidente michael bloomberg en
fin amigos este es
mike bloomberg el tipo con 50 mil
millones en la cartera que se presenta a
presidente quien pretende dar una patada
en el culo a donald trump un tipo que
hace que a su lado las andanzas de
donald en el mundo de los negocios
parezcan casi una broma en fin si te ha
gustado este vídeo no olvides darle al
botón de like y suscríbete a visual
polític si aún no lo has hecho un saludo
y hasta la próxima
awards
[Música]